[Music]
to many of us the work of spies takes
place in foreign embassies faraway
capitals and other exotic locales but
our next guest is found it is happening
on college campuses right here in the US
author Daniel Goldin went to Pulitzer
Prize for his series of articles in The
Wall Street Journal exposing the
admissions preferences at elite colleges
now his new book spy schools goes into
detail on how far inand domestic
intelligence services have turned
Institutes of higher learning into the
front lines of international espionage
Daniel Goldin welcome thanks good
morning what drew you to the subject
well I wrote an article a couple of
years ago about a professor at the
University of South Florida born in
China but a US citizen whom the FBI was
trying to pressure to spy on China and I
thought this was very unusual but as I
looked into it it turned out to be quite
commonplace and what I found was that
globalization was essentially creating
this kind of covert spy vs. 5 situation
on campus where there's so many foreign
students and researchers and visiting
scholars yeah some of them are looking
to poach research or recruit people and
at the same time the CIA and FBI are
using all kinds of tactics to recruit
those same foreigners and send them home
as our agents so both sides are kind of
exploiting universities and using the
the professors and the students as pawns
why is it easier to conduct intellectual
espionage as it were on college campuses
well college campus is a pretty open
transparent trusting places I mean
they're they're more open than like your
typical gated community you can walk
into a auditorium or a cafeteria and not
be checked and at the same time they're
very fruitful because there's a lot of
connections between universities and
government universities do a lot of
military and intelligence research a lot
of professors shuttle between
governments and universities and and
also you know young people the students
and graduate students that's an
impressionable age they can be easily
wooed so so it's kind of an attractive
low-risk thing it's I mean I think this
would surprise a lot of people I know
what even surprised John Licari the
espionage author who called your book a
timely and shocking and
the universities know that this is going
on and and if so why did they tolerate
it
well they I think they do know that it's
going on but they kind of turn a blind
eye because they have a lot of financial
motives to look the other way you know
foreign students provide a lot of
revenue they give a lot of contracts
with the government with the
intelligence agencies and military so
they don't want to push back too much
there and they're all looking to be
international and open foreign branches
that can be quite lucrative too you talk
in the book about an American named
Glenn Shriver who becomes sort of a
warning case who was he and why do we
need to know about him well he was a
American from a University in Michigan
Grand Valley State who went on a study
abroad program to China and eventually
China recruited him soon after he
graduated and paid him to try and
penetrate the CIA and he was caught and
and convicted what's interesting about
him is that he was sort of a typical
young American you know needed money so
he was susceptible to the intelligence
agencies a bit of an ego and they
praised him a lot and so I think you
know the the US intelligence looked at
this and said if they're interested in
him a lot of American students could be
vulnerable hmm recently Harvard's
Kennedy School rescinded an invitation
that Chelsea Manning to speak on campus
what does it say about the relationship
between universities and the
intelligence community well I think it
shows how close the ties are between
universities and the intelligence
community and the Kennedy School at
Harvard in particular has a whole web of
entanglements with the CIA and so they
can't afford to alienate these
intelligence agencies and in my book I I
uncover one particular aspect which is
that this a long line of CIA agents or
officers have gone to the Kennedy School
undercover using their foreign cover of
sort of State Department diplomats and
the programs they're in a predominately
foreign foreign businesspeople for in
future form foreign government leaders
and so they get a chance to cultivate
kind of these unsuspecting classmates
the book is spy schools Daniel Goldin
thank you very much for being with us
thanks it's my pleasure